mr speaker this government is committed
to improving station access for disabled
people in january 2018 and nusrat ghani
makes history by becoming the first
female muslim minister to speak from the
commons dispatch box
but two years later the conservative mp
says she was sacked from her position in
the department for transport because of
her muslim faith
the government's most senior enforcer
chief whip mark spencer has said he's
the person being referred to in the
claims but has categorically denied the
accusation
number 10 says boris johnson also met
with miss ghani at the time his deputy
today saying official channels had not
been used we have absolutely zero
tolerance for any discrimination any
islamophobia amnest hasn't made a formal
complaint she was asked to do so this uh
relates back to 2020
and in the absence of doing so uh there
will be no specific investigation into
this mr speaker
ghani says she was threatened with
reputational damage if she pursued the
issue and didn't think the complaint
system was appropriate
we need an investigation but i don't
want investigation from found ones
from the party let there be an
independent person coming in this goes
to the heart of attitude
of some people in the party
questions over islamophobia followed
boris johnson into downing street after
he compared muslim women to letterboxes
and bank robbers something sky news put
to him in 2019. you brought shame on
your party when you described veiled
muslim women as letter boxes
and bank robbers
well beth i i'm i'm i'm delighted that
um many of my former colleagues uh seem
to descend from from that view a
subsequent independent inquiry concluded
that anti-muslim sentiment was still a
problem within the tory party but many
accused the reports terms of reference
of not being thorough enough
nusrat ghani said her experience made
her feel humiliated and powerless she's
had support from cabinet ministers with
the health secretary sajid javid saying
she must be heard and the education
secretary nadim zahawi seemingly going
further than the government line and
calling for a full investigation
ahead of the publication of a report
into alleged parties in downing street
political opponents of the past point to
what they see as a terminal problem for
the prime minister we don't just have
the scandal we have the conflicts of
interest we have the
dubious appointments we have foreign
money and question marks over that who's
paying the bills for what and i don't
think we're going to see this
administration end in anything other
than scandal at his country retreat this
weekend boris johnson is fighting on
several fronts with spin-off scandals
doing damage and instability in the
ranks many now believe the shifting
political landscape will eventually
prove too much for the prime minister
rob powell sky news in westminster